[Musik]
ja
er hatte
[Musik]
nicht
die serien damen spanien jetzt noch
einige leute zu machen
wir folgen dem nicht rechnen schon
gemacht
schwächen
da müssen wir deswegen
aha
[Musik]
das bundesverfassungsgericht
bitte nehmen sie platz
guten morgen ich begrüße sie im
bundesverfassungsgericht und eröffnet
die sitzung des ersten senats des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zur verkündung
des urteils in dem verfahren 1 bvl 7 auf
16 zur verfassungsrechtlichen prüfung ob
§ 31a in verbindung mit paragrafen 31
und 31 b des zweiten buches
sozialgesetzbuch in der fassung vom 13
mai 2011 gültig ab ersten april 2011
erster insoweit mit artikel 1 absatz 1
grundgesetz in verbindung mit artikel 20
absatz 1 grundgesetz und dem sich daraus
ergebenden grundrecht auf gewährleistung
eines menschenwürdigen existenzminimums
vereinbar ist
als sich das für die sicherung des
soziokulturellen existenzminimums
maßgebliche arbeitslosengeld 2 aufgrund
von pflichtverletzungen um 30% bzw 60
das für die erwerbsfähige
leistungsberechtigte person maßgebenden
regelbedarfs mindert beziehungsweise bei
weiteren pflichtverletzungen vollständig
entfällt zweiter insoweit mit artikel 2
absatz 2 satz 1 grundgesetz vereinbar
ist als sanktionen wenn sie zu einer
lebens gefährdung oder beeinträchtigung
der gesundheit der sanktionierten führen
gegen das recht auf leben und
körperliche unversehrtheit verstoßen
drittens insoweit mit artikel 12
grundgesetz vereinbar ist
als sanktionen gegen die berufsfreiheit
verstoßen der heutigen urteilsverkündung
im verfahren 1 bvl 7 auf 16 liegt der
aussetzung und vorlagebeschluss des
sozialgerichts katar vom 2
august 2016 zu grunde
wir kommen zuerst zur feststellung der
anwesenheit ich möchte sie bitten sich
bei namensaufruf ist war gott sei dank
ja nur die zehn prozent auch wenn das
natürlich auch schon weh tut und ich
hatte glück dass er in diesen drei
monaten wirklich nichts ja wie sagt man
überraschendes reingekommen ist also das
hätte nichts kaputt gehen dürfen
oder wirklich die schuhe vom kind oder
ähnliches dann hätte ich ein problem
gehabt ja wie ist ihre einschätzung mit
welcher sanktionen bewirken mitarbeiter
im jobcenter am meisten mit der
mit der kleinen st uhr mit der großen
sanktionen was passiert wirklich ich
glaube es kommt auch wieder auf den
einzelfall an es kommt darauf an ob man
mit den menschen eine wirkung erzielt
die er selber auch für sich auch als als
als lösung auch ansieht das ist glaube
ich dass wichtiger wir können auch mit
einer 10 prozent sanktionen tatsächlich
auch einen kleinen schubs gegeben wenn
es darum geht mensch ich guck mal ob ich
bin ich pünktlich bin wir schicken in
der regel sms erinnerungen für diese
termine mit den hoffentlich nicht
vergisst in der regel haben wir die
möglichkeit zu sagen dann auch anzurufen
oder anderen termin auch damals zu
machen wenn sie nicht gar nicht wieder
klappen könnte
und wenn man sich an solche regel dann
auch hält dann kommt auch das man in der
regel auch keine leistungskürzung
bekommt es kann im einzelfall wie sie es
gerade geschildert haben dann doch
eintreten aber der prozesse
normalerweise so angelegt dass wird das
erlebens gespräch kommen wollen und
nicht kürzen wollen brauchen wir eben
die zahlen gesehen das ist das womit
menschen leben ist und auch die kürzung
mit denen sie aktuell leben müssen ihre
prognose werden werden dieses wird
dieses system bestand haben vor dem
grundgesetz prognosen sind immer
schwierig besonders vorher
ich glaube dass ganz wichtig das ist was
sie gesagt habe dass es auf den
einzelfall ankommt und ein problem
dieser regelung so wie sie ist ist dass
sie das sehr standardisiert vorgibt
deshalb habe ich durchaus zweifel das
verfassungsgericht legt bei grundrechten
wert darauf dass es um den einzelfall
geht dass der einzelne ein recht hat ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass es darauf
ankommen das war auch so in dem urteil
2010 also es wäre nicht völlig
überraschend
also die frage ist wie werden die
richterinnen und richter entscheiden und
ich höre es werden immer noch beteiligte
aufgerufen aber wir sind gehen schon in
richtung urteilsverkündung und können
ihnen versprechen dann schalten wir
gleich rüber in den großen sitzungssaal
und wollen aber noch mal die zeit kurz
nutzen um zu klären was ist ihr wunsch
was könnte im besten fall jetzt bei der
entscheidung gleich raus kommen dass wir
wahrscheinlich haben werden ist eben der
rechtssicherheit dass er also
tatsächlich die sicherheit haben dass
ist verfassungskonform oder eben auch
nicht und dann ist sicherlich auch der
gesetzgeber geforderte regelung zu
finden die wir nachher auch umsetzen
können womit dieser rechtssicherheit
sind wir glaube ich auch in unserem tun
vor ort mit den menschen dann auch noch
sicherer unterwegs und konnten
und auch darauf berufen dass ist geklärt
und ob sie diese rechtssicherheit
bekommen das erfahren wir jetzt hier
schauen in den großen sitzungssaal
es sieht danach aus dass fast alle
beteiligten aufgerufen sind und wir
haben einfach mal zu
denn frau monika paulat für den
deutschen anwaltverein herr rechtsanwalt
volker keller
wir kommen nun mehr zur
urteilsverkündung es wird folgendes
urteil verkündet im namen des volkes
aufgrund der mündlichen verhandlung vom
januar 2009 10 hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht erster senat
für recht erkannt
erstens § 31a absatz 1 sätze 1 2 und 3
sozialgesetzbuch zweites buch in der
fassung des gesetzes zur ermittlung von
regelbedarfe und zur änderung des
zweiten und zwölften buches
sozialgesetzbuch vom 24 märz 2011 sowie
der bekanntmachung der neufassung des
zweiten buches sozialgesetzbuch vom 13
mai 2011 geändert durch das gesetz zur
verbesserung der eingliederungschancen
am arbeitsmarkt vom zwanzigster dezember
2011 geändert durch das neue gesetz zur
änderung des zweiten buches
sozialgesetzbuch rechts vereinfachung
sowie zur vorübergehenden aussetzung der
insolvenzantragspflicht vom 26 juli 2016
ist für fälle des § 31 absatz 1
sozialgesetzbuch zweites buch in der
genannten fassung mit artikel 1 absatz 1
grundgesetz in verbindung mit dem
sozialstaatsprinzip des artikel 20
absatz 1 grundgesetz unvereinbar soweit
die höhe der leistungsminderung bei
einer erneuten verletzung einer pflicht
nach § 31 absatz 1 sozialgesetzbuch
zweites buch die höhe von 30 prozent des
maßgebenden regelbedarf es übersteigt so
weit eine sanktion nach § 31a absatz 1
sätze 1 bis 3 sozialgesetzbuch zweites
buch zwingend zu verhängen ist auch wenn
außergewöhnliche herten vorliegen und
soweit paragraf
31 b absatz 1 satz 3 sozialgesetzbuch
zweites buch für alle
leistungsminderungen ungeachtete
erfüllung einer mitwirkungspflicht oder
der bereitschaft dazu eine starre dauer
von drei monaten vor gibt zwei bis zum
inkrafttreten der neuregelung durch den
gesetzgeber sind § 31a absatz 1 sätze 1
2 und 3 und § 31 b absatz 1 satz 3 in
fällen des § 31 absatz 1
sozialgesetzbuch zweites buch in der
fassung folgen der übergangsregelungen
weiter anwendbar
§ 31a absatz 1 satz 1 sozialgesetzbuch
zweites buch ist in den fällen des § 31
absatz 1 sozialgesetzbuch zweites buch
mit der maßgabe anzuwenden dass die
leistungsminderung wegen einer
pflichtverletzung nach § 31 absatz 1 sgb
2 nicht erfolgen muss wenn diesem
konkreten einzelfall unter
berücksichtigung aller umstände zu einer
außergewöhnlichen härte führen würde
insbesondere kann von einer minderung
abgesehen werden wenn nach einschätzung
der behörde die zwecke des gesetzes nur
erreicht werden können indem eine
sanktion unterbleibt § 31a absatz 1
sätze 2 und 3 sozialgesetzbuch zweites
buch sind in den fällen des § 31 absatz
1 sozialgesetzbuch zweites buch mit der
maßgabe anwendbar
das wegen wiederholter
pflichtverletzungen eine minderung der
regelbedarf leistungen nicht über 30%
des maßgebenden regelbedarfs hinaus
gehen da von einer leistungsminderung
kann abgesehen werden wenn dies im
konkreten einzelfall unter
berücksichtigung aller umstände zu einer
außergewöhnlichen härte führen würde
insbesondere kann von einer minderung
abgesehen werden wir nach einschätzung
der behörde die zwecke des gesetzes nur
erreicht werden können indem eine
sanktion unterbleibt § 31 b absatz 1
satz 3 sozialgesetzbuch zweites buch ist
in den fällen des § 31 absatz 1
sozialgesetzbuch zweites buch mit
folgender maßgabe anzuwenden wird die
mitwirkungspflicht erfüllt oder erklären
sich leistungsberechtigte nachträglich
ernsthaft und nachhaltig bereich ihren
pflichten nachzukommen
kann die zuständige behörde unter
berücksichtigung aller umstände des
einzelfalls ab diesem zeitpunkt die
leistung wieder in vollem umfang
erbringen
die minderung darf ab diesem zeitpunkt
nicht länger als ein monat andauern
bitte nehmen sie platz
der senat hatte die frage zu entscheiden
ob die minderung von leistungen zur
sicherung des lebensunterhalts aufgrund
der verletzung gesetzlich normierter
mitwirkungs anforderungen bei
erwerbsfähigen leistungsberechtigten
fünfundzwanzigster lebensjahr vollendet
haben mit dem grundgesetz vereinbar ist
diese frage ist gesellschaftlich stark
streitbefangenen politisch hoch
kontrovers und juristisch schwierig der
senat hat sie nach intensiven beratungen
im ergebnis einstimmig beantwortet die
sozialrechtlichen regelungen die hier zu
beurteilen waren sind durchaus
kompliziert das zweite buch
sozialgesetzbuch regelt seit dem ersten
januar 2005 die leistungen zur sicherung
des lebensunterhalts durch die
grundsicherung für erwerbsfähige und für
diejenigen die mit ihnen in einer
bedarfsgemeinschaft leben
damit sollen bedarfe abgedeckt werden
die der gesetzgeber anerkannt hat um
eine menschenwürdige existenz zu sichern
der leistungsgewährung liegt das konzept
des förderns und forderns zugrunde
der staat stellt danach bestimmte
mitwirkungs anforderungen an
erwerbsfähige leistungsberechtigte um
sie dazu zu bringen wieder einer
erwerbsarbeit aufzunehmen
diese mitwirkungs anforderungen werden
mit zwischenzeitlich verschärften
zwingend zu verhängenden und starr drei
monate andauernden sanktionen in form
einer minderung des maßgebenden
regelbedarfs um zunächst 30 und dann 60
prozent und schließlich mit dem
vollständigen wegfall von leistungen
durchgesetzt
die zentralen verfassungsrechtlichen
anforderungen an den gesetzgeber für die
ausgestaltung der
grundsicherungsleistung für
erwerbsfähige ergeben sich aus der
grundrechtlichen gewährleistung eines
menschenwürdigen existenzminimums aus
artikel 1 absatz 1 in verbindung mit
artikel 20 absatz 1 grundgesetz
dies hat der senat in seinen
entscheidungen wiederholt betont
gesichert werden muss die physische und
soziokulturelle existenz als
einheitliche gewährleistung der
gesetzgeber davor sehen
existenzsichernde leistungen nur nach
maßgabe
der bedürftigkeit zur verfügung zu
stellen findet er staatliche leistungen
zur sicherung einer menschenwürdigen
existenz an die erfüllung von
mitwirkungspflichten die auf die
überwindung der hilfebedürftigkeit
zielen steht das grundgesetz dem nicht
entgegen der dem gesetzgeber ist es auch
nicht verwehrt instrumente zu schaffen
um derartige mitwirkungspflichten
durchzusetzen
indes müssen sowohl die mitwirkungs
anforderungen selbst als auch die
sanktionen zu ihrer durchsetzung den
anforderungen der verhältnismäßigkeit
entsprechen
sie sind hinsichtlich der
leistungsminderungen besonders streng
der gesetzgeber hat sich für eine
sanktion entschieden vorübergehend
existenzsichernde leistungen zu
entziehen und operiert damit in einem
grund rechtlich besonders sensiblen
bereich der gesetzgeber schafft hier für
die betroffenen menschen denen dann ein
teil des existenzminimums fehlt eine
außerordentliche belastung grundsätzlich
hat die politik einen
einschätzungsspielraum zur eignung
erforderlichkeit und zumutbarkeit von
regelungen zur ausgestaltung des
sozialstaates
dieser ist hier aber beschränkt weil es
um das existenzminimum geht
je länger die entsprechenden regelungen
in kraft sind und es also möglich ist zu
ihren wirkungen fundierte einschätzungen
zu erlangen
umso weniger genügt es sich allein auf
plausible annahmen zu stützen
ob die sanktionen ihre ziele auch
tatsächlich erreichen
es muss den betroffenen zudem
tatsächlich möglich sein
die minderung existenzsichernde
leistungen durch eigenes verhalten in
zumutbarer zeit abzuwenden
diese verfassungsrechtlichen vorgaben
zeigen das grundgesetz schützt
hilfebedürftige es baut ihnen brücken in
eine bessere zukunft der gesetzgeber
darf verlangen dass menschen die
staatliche mittel in anspruch nehmen
diese brücken auch beschreiten
er unterliegt aber strengen
anforderungen wenn er vorübergehend die
mittel entzieht die zum leben
erforderlich sind
für die dem senat gestellten fragen
bedeutet dies die zu überprüfenden
regelungen sind im ausgangspunkt mit dem
grundgesetz vereinbar
der gesetzgeber kann erwerbsfähigen
leistungsberechtigten die in § 31 absatz
1 sgb 2 geregelten mitwirkungspflichten
auferlegen damit sie zumutbar an der
überwindung ihrer eigenen bedürftigkeit
aktiv mitwirken
er kann sich auch dafür entscheiden die
verletzung dieser pflichten zu
sanktionieren in dem leistungen
vorübergehend gemindert werden
die gesetzliche ausgestaltung dieser
minderungen wird den dafür geltenden
strengen anforderungen der
verhältnismäßigkeit aber in
verschiedener hinsicht nicht gerecht
dabei spielt eine entscheidende rolle
das bislang nur begrenzte erkenntnisse
zu den wirkungen solcher sanktionen
vorliegen eine umfassende
wissenschaftliche untersuchung dieser
wirkungen liegt trotz der regelung in §
55 sgb 2 nicht vor
die mündliche verhandlungen die vielen
stellungnahmen in diesem verfahren haben
gezeigt dass ich hier einen
tatsächlichen viele noch unbeantwortete
fragen stellen vor diesem hintergrund
ist die in § 31 absatz 1 satz 1 sgb 2
normierte höhe einer minderung um 30%
früher massgebenden regelbedarf derzeit
nicht zu beanstanden
allerdings genügt die zwingende vorgabe
auch in fällen außergewöhnliche härte
existenzsichernde leistungen zu mindern
den strengen verhältnismäßigkeit
anforderungen ebenso wenig wie die
unabhängig von der nachträglichen
mitwirkung der betroffenen starr
vorgegebenen dauer der minderung von
drei monaten
der gesetzgeber kann sich auch
grundsätzlich dafür entscheiden im fall
wiederholte pflichtverletzung härter zu
sanktionieren
auf grundlage der derzeitigen
erkenntnisse ist eine minderung in höhe
von 60% des regelbedarfs aber nicht
zumutbar und deshalb
verfassungsrechtlich nicht zu
rechtfertigen auch der vollständige
wegfallen des arbeitslosengeldes 2 ist
nach derzeitigem erkenntnisstand mit den
verfassungsrechtlichen maßgaben nicht
vereinbar
die in diesem verfahren überprüften
regelungen verstoßen daher gegen artikel
1 absatz 1 in verbindung mit artikel 20
absatz 1 grundgesetz § 31a absatz 1
sätze 1 2 und 3 und § 31 b absatz 1 satz
3 sgb 2 sind in den fällen
§ 31 absatz 1 sgb 2 mit dem grundgesetz
unvereinbar
das sind nicht die fälle der
meldeversäumnisse oder der sanktionen
gegenüber unter 25-jährigen diese lagen
dem senat nicht zur entscheidung vor
der gesetzgeber hat für die vom senat
überprüften fälle neu zu regeln ob und
wie pflichtverletzungen nach § 31 absatz
1 sgb 2 sanktioniert werden
bis dahin gilt eine übergangsregelung
die sanktionsregelungen können bis zum
inkrafttreten der neuregelung nach
maßgabe des urteils weiter angewendet
werden
eine sanktion in höhe von 30 prozent
kann weiter verhängt werden
sie muss aber nicht erfolgen wenn das im
konkreten einzelfall unter
berücksichtigung aller umstände zu einer
außergewöhnlichen härte führen würde
insbesondere kann von einer solchen
minderung abgesehen werden wenn nach
einschätzung der behörde die zwecke des
gesetzes nur erreicht werden können
indem eine sanktion unterbleibt
außerdem kann die zuständige behörde
unter berücksichtigung aller umstände
des einzelfalls die leistung wieder in
vollem umfang erbringen wenn die
mitwirkungspflicht nachträglich doch
erfüllt wird oder sofern dies nicht
möglich ist sich leistungsberechtigte
nachträglich ernsthaft und nachhaltig
bereit erklären ihren pflichten
nachzukommen
die minderung darf ab diesem zeitpunkt
jedenfalls nicht länger als einen
weiteren monat andauern
wegen wiederholter pflichtverletzungen
darf eine minderung der regelbedarf
leistungen allerdings nicht über 30% des
maßgebenden regelbedarf hinausgehen der
gesetzgeber darf also von menschen
verlangen dass sie die brücke in die
erwerbsarbeit beschreiten wenn er das im
bereich des grundrechtlich geschützten
existenzminimums sanktioniert darf er
aber nicht zu weit gehen so weit kurz
skizziert die wesentlichen gründe die
den senat zu seiner entscheidung bewogen
haben nunmehr folgt die begründung im
einzelnen
das waren so die kernsätze der
entscheidung und jetzt folgt die
ausführliche begründung das heißt wir
haben die entscheidung gerade bekommen
es sind 74 seiten die werden jetzt noch
einmal verlesen das waren jetzt die
kernsätze die für sie für uns alle für
die öffentlichkeit vor allem bestimmt
waren um so den grundsatz dieser
entscheidung zu verstehen und es hat
doch
aufhorchen lassen das
bundesverfassungsgericht sie haben es
gerade gehört hat im grunde gesagt ja
man darf bedingungen an dieses
existenzminimum knüpfen
aber nicht alle und wir wollen jetzt
noch mal in dieser runde besprechen was
ist er genau entschieden worden und
deshalb zuerst die frage direkt an sie
frau wallrabenstein voll
sanktionierungen geht nicht mehr aber
sanktioniert werden darf weiter und es
gilt ab sofort so viel habe ich
verstanden klären sie uns auf
ja es waren zwei sehr sehr lange sätze
am anfang
es ist nicht in ordnung sagt das
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt zu
sanktionieren mit letztlich mehr als 30
prozent also die 30% sanktionen hat es
gesagt das geht so die 60 und die 100%
sanktionen geht nicht und dann hat es
außerdem im zweiten satz gesagt bis der
gesetzgeber das regelt wir es jetzt denn
dann neue haben will in den
entsprechenden paragrafen gilt dass man
jetzt nur im ergebnis die 30% sanktionen
verhängt und in den anderen fällen wo
vorher 60 und 100 stand auch 30 prozent
sanktioniert
das heißt ganz konkret ab sofort im
ändert sich für jeden hartz 4 empfänger
ganz grundsätzlich war so klang das also
ab jetzt sofort sozusagen gibt es nicht
höhere sanktionen als die 30 prozent
sanktionen die bescheide die vielleicht
anhängig sind die könnte man die die
gibt's frisch ergangen sind könnte man
vielleicht angreifen das hängt das
tatsächlich vom einzelfall ab und ich
habe noch was anderes gehört was ich
ehrlich gesagt fast noch wichtiger finde
das gericht hat sehr viel vom einzelfall
gesprochen dass er sich vorher gesagt
habe dass man im einzelfall die die
jobcenter gucken müssen wenn jemand
ernsthaft sagt ich komme jetzt ich mach
jetzt das was er vorher nicht gemacht
hat dann muss die sanktion auch verkürzt
werden also man muss im und im härtefall
muss auch geschaut werden ob man
überhaupt trotz fehlverhaltens also
trotz nicht richtigen verhaltens jetzt
überhaupt funktionieren kann im
härtefall nämlich nicht das ist schon
ziemlich neu würde ich sagen ja das
heißt im grunde ist das eingetreten was
sie ein bisschen befürchtet haben die
mitarbeiter im jobcenter haben noch mehr
ermessensspielraum mit dem einzelfall
sich den anzuschauen oder können noch
stärker mit den menschen ins gespräch
kommen das ist ja auch ein aspekt dieser
ganz
dass wir also tatsächlich noch
intensiver und noch individueller prüfen
ist es die richtige arbeit das ist die
richtige aktivierungsmaßnahmen und auch
das thema melde versorgen das hat der
richter ja auch gesagt ist man erstmal
unbenommen von dieser ganzen geschichte
nur so ein ermessensspielraum kann
natürlich auch überprüft verlangt haben
sie dann nicht angst dass jetzt anwälte
kommen die dann jeden bescheid anfechten
weil je mehr ermessen sie haben desto
mehr angriffsfläche bietet man ja auch
gut aber wir versuchen natürlich das wir
messen auf pflichtgemäße auszuüben auch
mit dieser messens ausübung auch
richtige entscheidungen zu treffen und
auch eine formulierung hat mir sehr gut
gefallen im sinne des gesetzes zu
handeln das ist glaube ich auch unser
anspruch dass er im sinne des gesetzes
handeln eben die menschen tatsächlich
auf dem weg in arbeit zu begleiten
sie waren eben ganz erstaunt ist
ungewöhnlich normalerweise gibt das
bundesverfassungsgericht ein auftrag an
den gesetzgeber
meistens selbst auch eine frist bis
irgendwann muss hier neues gesetz
gemacht werden in diesem fall gilt es ab
sofort wie erklären sie sich dass das
das bundesverfassungsgericht ihr diesen
weg gegangen ist
also das war sehr klar wir uns auch
gerade gehört des gesetzes
verfassungswidrig das heißt der
gesetzgeber muss jetzt was neu regeln
jetzt wissen wir dass du was oft recht
lange dauert und deshalb es ist wirklich
auch wichtig dass das gericht jetzt sagt
wie es ab heute weitergeht
das hat es genauso getan mit dem urteil
zum asylbewerberleistungsgesetz wo es
auch gesagt hat die leistung sind zu
niedrig und ab morgen gilt gilt etwas
anderes weil die leute nicht wenn es ums
existenzminimum geht auf den sankt
nimmerleinstag warten können und deshalb
macht das bundesverfassungsgericht ich
finde das konsequent weil es genau so
ist die 2012 ist hier so dass er selber
sagt das gilt ab sofort weil es um das
existenzminimum geht mit dieser
entscheidung ändert sich unmittelbar das
leben aller hat vier leistungsempfänger
was sagen sie zu der entscheidung genau
das war auch erst mal mein mann mein
erster gedanke
es ändert sich jetzt alles also da wird
jetzt ganz viele auch im prüfstand
genommen
es gibt den menschen jetzt auch mehr
möglichkeit eben diese einzelfall
entscheidung dass man viel mehr
mitspracherecht hat dass man auch mal
was begründen kann usw
das ist jetzt alles besser geregelt ich
denke der arbeitsmarkt wird sich dadurch
auch ändern also ich glaube das wird
jetzt eine ganze menge passieren ich bin
froh dass es so gekommen ist auch wenn
natürlich immer noch unter das
existenzminimum gegangen werden darf das
bleibt natürlich trotzdem
wir schauen uns nochmal wir hatten ja
eben schon mal die grafik aufgerufen mit
den zahlen um zu schauen um welche
sanktionen geht es hier eigentlich ganz
genau und jetzt sehen wir die grafik
noch einmal voll aufgebaut und sehen
also die erste kürzung die hier sehen
wir gar nicht also das sind die 42 euro
die bleiben aber danach wenn man einen
job ablehnt also und den zweiten und den
dritten die voll kürzung das geht alles
weg frauen haben scheint können sie uns
anhand der grafik nochmal erzählen was
sich ab heute mit diesem tag an dieser
grafik ändert an den zahlen ändert die
diese grafik zeigt also diese erste
zeile wo dasteht - 127 euro dies
weiterhin möglich mit einer besseren
beobachtung des einzelfalles unter
berücksichtigung des einzelfalls aber
auf 681 euro kann es tatsächlich nur
runter gehen also das ist nicht so dass
gar nichts mehr stattfinden kann
der staat kann was verlangen aber die
anderen beiden gruppen hier die gibt es
nicht mehr
die unteren beiden zeilen und zwar mit
dem tag heute
wir haben vorab einmal menschen in
berlin auf der straße gefragt was sie
eigentlich zu diesen hat vier leistung
und kürzungen fragen das war natürlich
vor der verkündung und die ansichten
waren waren da sehr unterschiedlich ich
will aber noch einmal kurz frau tender
offer abfragen es hat sich ja nicht
alles geändert also das
verfassungsgericht hat gesagt ist wird
weiter an bedingungen geknüpft ist das
fast was sie enttäuscht oder sagen sie
dann da gehe ich mit vollsanierung war
falsch 60 prozent war falsch aber dass
man ein bisschen sanktionieren kann
finde ich richtig
also ich glaube deswegen finde ich gut
dass es diese einzelfall entscheidung
gibt natürlich gibt es in diesem system
menschen die das system ausnutzen und
dass man da vielleicht eher hinguckt und
da sagt dann müssen wir was tun das
verstehe ich aber der große teil die ich
auch kenne benehmen sich so wie sie sich
benehmen müssten und sollen und die
sollten auch gefördert werden da sollte
man wirklich hingucken muss man da
wirklich sanktionieren muss man da was
machen ihre geben wir nicht erst mal ans
telefon machen erstmal was das bin nicht
ich glaube dieser punkt wird sich jetzt
auch drastisch ändern dass das jetzt
eher so gehandhabt wird das heißt aus
ihrer sicht ein gerechtes urteil
nein immer noch nicht ganz es wird es
darf immer noch gekürzt werden ein
existenzminimum das ist das was mir
nicht in den kopf fällt
wir haben vorab menschen auf der straße
in berlin gefragt was sie gerecht finden
und da war mein kollege felix zimmermann
unterwegs und wir hören uns dieses
stimmen einmal an braucht man eine
andere lösung als den leuten das so
runter zu kürzen dass sie dann als wir
sich suppenküche und wohnung verlieren
und davon haben wir schon so viel es ist
ja auch schwer sehr schwer wieder ins
arbeitsleben rein zu kommen wenn man
erst mal zehn jahre nichts gemacht hat
und dann diese mentale umstellung und
landtag wieder rein zu rutschen
ja ich sag mal für sein geld muss
natürlich auch etwas angeboten bekommt
natürlich auch arbeiten bisher unklar
ich finde es schwierig so was zu
sanktionieren ich denke der
hartz-iv-satz ist sowieso so niedrig
dass man grundsätzlich schon am
existenzminimum ist viele leute haben
vielleicht auch psychische probleme und
deshalb schwierigkeiten auf dem
arbeitsmarkt und deshalb sollten wir uns
als deutschland das leisten können
solche leute auch weiter zu unterstützen
die grundlagen müssen da erhalten seien
immer es kann nicht sein dass jemand
plötzlich dann eine wohnung ist und ohne
geld um sich essen zu brauchen und so
weiter das geht nicht
gehört die grund sachen essen wohnen
muss erhalten bleiben und genau das sagt
die entscheidung hier heute auch am
bundesverfassungsgericht und ändert
damit also die gesetzeslage so wie sie
heute noch um 9 uhr 59 war sagen auch
sie ist das ein gerechtes urteil hier
also ich glaube es ist auch wichtig zu
sehen dass wir gerade sagte mehrzahl die
weitaus grösste mehrzahl der menschen
die zu uns kommen die halten sich auch
an die regel wir kommen mit denen auch
gemeinsam ins gespräch und den gegen dem
eine leistungskürzung geben müssen sind
bei uns im dorf sind 87 prozent wegen
meldeversäumnissen weitere fünf prozent
die dann wegen der arbeitsaufnahme und
davon wurden ganz kleiner bruchteil der
die zweite oder dritte leistungskürzung
bekommt also es geht tatsächlich nur um
die wirklich um den letzten schritt um
die ultima ratio wenn wirklich gar
nichts mehr geht in der zusammenarbeit
dann tritt das ein und das ist jetzt
anscheinend nicht mehr zulässig und das
ist dann für dieses verfahren eben auch
möglich und ist es ist also ist das
schwierig für sie in der täglichen
arbeit dass diese voll sanktionierung
die ganze härte nicht mehr möglich ist
also wir geben mit jeder rechtslage um
mit dem sind also ich würde das jetzt
nicht beurteilen zu sagen schwierig oder
nicht schwierig wesentlich ist im
einzelfall mit den menschen ins gespräch
zu kommen und bisher hat auch eine
solche voll sang zum manchmal zu einem
erfolg in anführungszeichen gefühl dass
sie ein verhalten auch geändert hat in
dem sinne wenn vielleicht auch jetzt die
30 prozent reichen dieses verhalten zu
ändern wäre das auch vollkommen okay was
wir eben gerade in der umfrage gehört
haben so legten gedanken der menschen
die wir da getroffen haben war ja also
auf der einen seite hat vier ist ein
minimum da kann man doch nicht ran auf
der anderen seite soll auch jeder
genügend haben wohnen essen da soll man
nicht ran aber bewegen soll schon sein
ist das jetzt nicht alles erfüllt ist
das ein perfektes gerechtes urteil was
sagen sie perfekt ist da gar nichts ist
ja so also das was wir auch gerade
gehört haben oder auch das rauschen sorg
gesagt das was man mit grundsicherung
bekommt ist das existenzminimum und dass
es irgendwas da drunter geben soll ist
von der logik her schlecht zu begreifen
es gibt aber eben auch die andere logik
die wir ja auch schon gesagt haben es
ist auch okay das würde ich auch so
sehen dass der staat sagt dass knüpfe
ich an bestimmte bedingungen ich muss
das nicht bedingungslos ausgestalten
ich kann mit dieser idee verleben und
dann lebe ich
mit diesem widerspruch dass ich
irgendwie keine 100 prozent reine lösung
hinbekommen in der einen oder anderen
variante und da sich durch zu lavieren
ist jetzt aufgabe des gesetzgebers ja
das absolut perfekte gerechte gibt es
nie aber es ist erstaunlich wie nah die
richterinnen und richter am
bundesverfassungsgericht in diesem fall
an das absolut perfekte direktor
angekommen sind so dass zumindest die
widerstreitenden interessen hier relativ
zufrieden sind mit der entscheidung wie
sie hier heute ausgegangen ist und
deshalb bedanke ich mich für ihr
interesse
hier an dieser entscheidung ich bedanke
mich bei ihnen dass sie hier heute ihre
meinungen und ansichten und erfahrungen
mit uns geteilt haben und gibt zurück
nach bonn
vielen dank und wir haben uns jetzt
dankeschön von den phoenix zuschauern
verabschiedet bleiben aber weiterhin
hier live zu sehen auf der zdf facebook
seite in der hoffnung dass uns fragen
von ihnen erreicht haben die wir hier
noch in die runde geben und mit der
runde diskutieren können und ich sehe
gerade ich habe hier jetzt noch keine
aktuellen fragen
doch hier ich sehe kommentaren ankommt
ich kenne diese aber noch nicht ich lese
die hier live mit ihnen vor und gibt die
dann an denjenigen der sie sich traut
sich sie den sie zu beantworten
litter chamäleon auf facebook schreibt
was passiert mit den menschen im falle
einer voll sanktionierung stromrechnung
miete heizkosten fragezeichen die person
macht dann ja schulden und kann in
wohnungslosigkeit enden
darauf hat haben die richtige antwort
gefunden das war bisher eine möglichkeit
aber das ist ja weg das passiert nicht
mehr an die wohnung an die kosten für
wohnung und unterkunft kommt jetzt auch
keine sanktionen mehr daran glaubt dass
ganz wichtig also durch eine sanktion
kann keiner ja seine wohnung verlieren
der verfügbare das geld was man zur
verfügung hat das wird aber immer noch
ein bisschen weniger aber nur noch in
anführungsstrichen der teil
im extremfall ja auch so bei einer
lichtleistung entfällt auf der
krankenversicherungsschutz nach einem
monat das ist jetzt auch damit weg ja
das heißt diese frage haben die richter
direkt beantwortet zweite fall die uns
erreicht hat ist von utah zinecker auch
auf facebook
es muss einen anreiz geben sich wieder
dem arbeitsmarkt verfügbar zu machen und
angebote nicht abzulehnen kürzungen sind
das resultat einer verweigerung niemand
wird das geld niemandem wird das geld
gekürzt der aus der situation heraus
will
wie sollte man sonst als start entgegen
wirken was antworten sie darauf
ich kenne diese ganzen ja vorwürfe oder
unterstellungen und so die meisten
menschen wollen wieder in arbeit
und ich finde ich meinem grundgesetz
geht auch steht auch jeder darf sich
auch die arbeit aussuchen die er möchte
und im normalfall wenn man nicht im
hartz-iv-bezug ist fragt ja auch keiner
warum fängst du da nicht an das hast du
doch sofort angeboten bekommen oder
warum machst du das du da nicht ja da
wird nicht hinterfragt aber in dem fall
wird hinterfragt und man muss vielleicht
auch entgegen seinen prinzipien
vielleicht eine arbeitsstelle annehmen
die man sonst nie genommen hätte
aber ist es nicht also um geld also
umgekehrt wenn man drauf schaut führt
diejenigen hartz iv empfänger die sich
bemühen die engagiert sind die auch jobs
annehmen die nicht erste wahl sind und
das macht man ja auch immer nicht hat
hier bezieht das manchmal ein job macht
der jetzt nicht der traumjob ist ist das
für die nicht ungerecht wenn diejenigen
die sagt mach ich nicht ich mache hier
nicht mit wenn wenn wenn die nicht
sanktioniert werden
bisher war es ja so dass sie diese jobs
auch angenommen haben weil sie angst vor
den sanktionen haben das darf man auch
nicht vergessen
deswegen sagte ich vorher das wird sich
jetzt einiges ändern vielleicht hat man
jetzt eher die möglichkeit sich dann
auch wirklich die möglichkeit das
arbeiten heraus suchen wo man sagt das
ist genau das was ich machen möchte aber
bis man die arbeit bekommt kann man
abwarten um oder nein also ich glaub mir
gesagt ich glaube die meisten menschen
so bin ich auch wollen in arbeit und
schauen auch ja es geht nur darum
man kann nicht einfach dann einen job
gedrängt werden dem man vielleicht gar
nicht gelernt hat oder ähnliches und da
finde ich absolut verständlich wenn man
dann sagt sorry das ist nicht meins das
damit habe ich noch nie zu tun gehabt
das traue ich mich nicht so und kann
nicht mehr sanktioniert werden teilen
sie das verständnis nach meinem
verständnis gerade gehört haben bleibt
die erste sanktionen bestehen dass er
das erste jobangebot was zumutbar ist so
wird dann wieder wenn es entsprechend
nicht eintritt mit einer
leistungskürzung gelegt werden falls der
erste gedanke zu sagen arbeit
aufzunehmen die mir angeboten wird das
auch zu tun
glaube ich sollte auch so bleiben aber
es bleibt ja erst jetzt deutlich
kalkulierbarer weil man maximal 42 oder
127 euro maximal hymne nicht dass also
das ist also wie viel vom wenigen
gehören also keine frage aber es ist
kalkulierbar schlimmer wird's nicht ja
was meinen sie was das verändern wird
ich glaube das ist nicht erstrebenswert
ich glaube nicht dass menschen also
jedenfalls die nicht die weitaus mehr
zahl kalkuliert wie viel geld ich
verkraften kann um was abzulehnen ich
glaube dass da ganz falsche ansatz es
geht darum zu sagen arbeit aufzunehmen
welche arbeit kann ich auf den welche
arbeit ist dass linda gerade sagte kann
ich unter aufbringung aller meiner
anstrengungen dennoch auf mich nehmen um
dann entsprechend dann auch aus der
grundsicherung rauszukommen
das ist da der antrieb den die menschen
auch haben das sagen sie was glauben sie
dass sich das veränderte habe auch ein
bisschen gezockt
das verfassungsgericht hat schon gesagt
so wie das jetzt ist von leuten gibt
denen der staat grundsicherung gibt darf
der staat etwas verlangen und er darf
auch verlangen dass ihr einen job
annehmen den sie nicht wollen also dass
da scheint das gericht nicht dran
gedanken sein und das was die facebook
fahren hier schrieb zu sagen das darf
ich doch auch erwarten irgendwas
verfasst uns gelaufen
es ist aber ein bisschen eine andere
frage was darf der staat machen um das
was er erwartet auch durchzusetzen
und er darf die leute nicht zwingen das
durfte er auch vorher nicht das war
nicht die frage aber darf er ihn deshalb
auch leistungen kürzen und da sagt auch
das gericht ja schon aber nicht mit dem
rasenmäher und nicht pauschal sondern im
einzelfall das ändert etwas genauer zu
diesem einzelfall hatten noch eine
facebook-nutzerin eine frage heike
schmidt schreibt nämlich wer bestimmt
denn dann was soziale härte ist
frage das ist noch nicht klar
herausgekommen ist glaube ich ein
unbestimmter rechtsbegriff wir haben
darüber gesprochen oder ist es
ermessensausübung das werden wir im
weiteren verfahren sehen es geht aber
noch mal aber geht ja die umfragen ja
aber es geht um das gespräch es geht um
den dialog wenn man also spricht ist
dieser job zumutbar von den
rahmenbedingungen her von der
arbeitszeit von der anreise vor der
qualifikation auch vom gehalt her und
wenn man darüber spricht und der
bewerber sagt okay das möchte ich da
kommt man auch gut zusammen
wenn er sagt das möchte ich nicht
stellen wir automatisch um die frage was
denn dann
also es geht eigentlich nicht darum zu
sagen etwas nicht zu tun sondern
eventuell etwas anderes zu tun um sich
zu aktivieren oder den den
leistungsbezug zu beenden schwierig wird
es immer zu sagen ich mache gar nichts
das ist immer dann schwieriger einsatz
ja ich schaue gerade ob wir noch weitere
fragen über facebook bekommen haben
das ist nicht der fall dann bedanke ich
mich bei ihnen dass sie hier heute auch
noch mal der facebook-nutzer gemeinde
fragen beantwortet haben
das ist immer wichtig weil weil da dann
auch direkt kommt was die zuschauer
interessiert und bewegt und bedanke mich
bei ihnen für das interesse für das
fragenstellen fürs mitdiskutieren und
die diskussion hat vermutlich gerade
erst begonnen denn mit der entscheidung
heute 10 uhr hat sich für viele im land
sehr viel verändert vielen dank